before we get started uh i do this every
time i get to talk to hugh i just want
to remind everyone watching this
interview that cloud atlas is a
masterpiece and you need to watch it if
you have never seen it uh it is a
phenomenal movie i just have to say that
every time because i love that movie so
much now we can talk to why you know
anything else you want guys want to talk
about
i think it's a fantastic movie myself
thanks
steve i've come to really love you in
the last 24 hours
the movie's amazing um so for both of
you guys if someone has actually never
seen anything that you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
to watch and why
i don't know i i don't have any
i don't have any i'd like them to see
this film i mean that's that's so
self-serving but i i do i
i only like the movies that i've just
done i've never liked the ones that i've
done previously i always think of the
the things that we
we that went wrong you know and and the
one that i've not seen yet that i've
just finished i know is going to be
brilliant
and then i see it and you know
i don't know if it lives up to
expectations or not but i think this one
does
that was very philosophical answer but
not very clear this one's great i've
heard i've heard this from a lot of
actors though um uh
i can assume that you're not a fan of
watching yourself on screen not not
particularly no yeah i've i've heard
this from from a number of people um
hugh do you have a film that or some
project on the contrary i love to watch
myself and in fact i noticed
that my children watch me every night if
they don't they don't get fed
they can make the film but they have to
watch a daddy film every night
uh
i'm curious what they think about
paddington too but anyway moving into uh
so you guys have both worked with guy
before and what's fascinating about guy
as a filmmaker is he likes to rework the
script on the day of filming and um you
know he plays he's very spontaneous
which is unlike many other directors can
you sort of talk about collaborating
with him and you know what's it really
like on set um each day well it's
alarming that is alarming
up to a point and i i have had tense
moments with him about it because i i've
i don't know why i like very very deep
thorough preparation it makes me
marginally less terrified on the day
but uh
but actually there is another way to go
about the whole acting business which is
to think well i'm not i have no
preparation let's let's just wing it and
in a way that takes pressure off
because you think well if there was no
script and i didn't have to learn it and
uh
there's no expectation here so it can
work in your favor but it's it's
alarming it's alarming to to
act commando the whole time
acting commando is about exactly the way
you have to put it it's scary at first
but once you rip the band-aid off uh
it's
uh i think it's
i think it's comforting knowing that
the director
is not exactly certain what he wants
until he sees it and then when he sees
it it's locked in and i
that me that to me
means that he's really paying attention
and that he's sculpting something in the
moment and that's yes i agree with that
and it's it's odd how many directors
really good directors i've found
are like this they're not script
orientated very much they don't they're
not forever looking at the script
they're not they don't have a
preconceived notion of how a line should
sound or how a scene should sound
stephen fries was the same uh he
he could barely tell you
what scene you're shooting but he sits
there at the monitor and expects to be
entertained
because when it's
entertaining and when it's not that
that's his only criteria yeah
and i think that's probably is good film
directing because that's the medium it
is it's you've got to entertain people
through that screen
and uh
nothing too pre-rehearsed
i i loved uh your two characters in the
film and the way you both worked
together on screen it made me laugh a
lot especially stuff in the third act um
can you sort of talk about work like uh
what you enjoyed working about working
with each other and who was the one who
made each other laugh the most from you
know whatever they were doing
i could tell you hugh made me laugh
way better than i should
josh i ruined a few tapes it's a
charming subplot actually you and me
it is it is
i think that's the spin-off
if there's a spin-off from this movie it
will be
we adopted
greg in hollywood yeah no i think you
you bring out the best in me and i give
up arms dealing and we set up a little
antique shop in brighton
right in palm springs it'll be great
let's do it yeah squabble a little but
we're happy we're basically happy yeah
basically there's more than you can
expect from most partnerships yeah
one of the things uh aubry is very funny
and i'm curious if you guys could talk a
little bit about working with her
because i know some of the things she
says in the movie are things that she
came up with and i would imagine she
caused many many scenes to resolve and
you know laughter so what was it like
working with her
well yeah she's she's a great comedian
and
and uh
you don't you really really don't know
which way she's going to go at any
moment but not only on the set but off
the set
i've had dinner with about 10 different
orders
yeah yeah yeah i i would agree with that
i think aubrey is uh is multi-talented
uh and we we
we had a lot of fun
on set trying to figure out
like
exactly who was gonna get the snarky
remark
uh it was always
hugh i think
we ended up getting
getting the bro the bun the brunt of it
uh but uh but you know it was
yeah i mean being from my perspective
being able to kind of improvise with
these guys was was really
was intimidating aubry is great at it he
was great at it
jason's great i mean it's all just it's
all
i was the only one who they had to help
along with training wheels that's not
true josh
i had one good one and it made it into
the film club what was it
the lance armstrong one wait wait not
lance armstrong
i
i i think i know what joke you're
talking about it's not him but you know
exactly uh i am this is obviously a film
that as you said as we talked about is
more improvised in the moment and you
know on set but uh i'm always fascinated
talking with actors about the way they
prepare for like a really tough scene
something that is scripted so for both
of you if you have something on like a
monday that you know is going to be
tough to do something that's going to
require
you know more out of you can you sort of
talk about how you're getting ready for
a sequence like that are you really far
out thinking about it or are you more
closer to the actual day of filming
where you're really getting into it
well for me it's both i'll start
panicking about that scene months before
and uh
you know i call it my tooth combing i go
through the script in unbelievably fine
detail and
and ask myself why why do you say that
why does he do that and how do you link
the thoughts together
and every day you come to it
you have a slightly different
perspective on it and you understand it
a bit more
and it's it's like i would call it
marinading you sort of marinade in the
scene you marinade in the character
and then on the day hopefully you throw
away all your prep
and try and uh
just find it in the moment sometimes you
have to go away and
get in the mood it's quite hard
you know especially if it's a maybe
everyone else is quite chipper that day
and
you know
having a good time having a laugh on the
set and you've got to do tears then you
know it's that's a nightmare you're
going to hide yourself away listen to
your sad playlist
uh
it's it's it's traumatic but anyway i i
have found in old age i cry at the drop
of a hat i now have to be asked not to
cry in scenes rather than to to cry how
about you josh
i'm going to say that i'm going to say
that i agree with you 100 on prep but
then on a film like this where guy is
coming up a new dialogue the last minute
and maybe a new
uh direction for your character entirely
you can't you aren't afforded that that
luxury you don't in a way that makes it
better
this is when working with a
director-like guy it makes it better
because
you know it's all about spontaneity it's
all about listening
and uh and reacting which
really is what as you've said hugh what
the camera likes on that note i need to
stop i'm just going to say uh thank you
so much for entertaining me with this
movie and i wish you both nothing but
the best thank you very much
you